we also in love with jasmine over the
course of her journey to find love on
last season's hit show The Bachelor I
Canada and now she's joining me in
studio to fill us in on what happened
with her and Kevin since the cameras
stopped rolling so yeah how are things
things they're really good yeah he's
really good yep doing the long-distance
thing for now and it's been good
spinnable nine months it's almost like
that's a long time crazy it doesn't seem
like much everybody but it was end of
May yeah so would we say that
potentially you could be moving to
Toronto that's a potential thing yeah
I'm mentally wrapping my head around it
right now but I don't have any absolute
set in stone plans of when I would come
but we're talking about Springs as for
runner up Mikael he was the fan favorite
but had since moved on and fallen in
love we have kept in touch here and
there and yeah he's an awesome guy he's
been a relationship he seems really
happy and she seems like a really sweet
girl so people you gotta let that go I
know I need to just move on there all of
that right yeah and if you're ready to
find love like Yasmine and Kevin you too
can addition to be part of one of
Canada's biggest reality shows what can
you tell people who are auditioning to
this show what sort of tip okay we
really did something yeah okay so I
think the best thing is to go in with no
expectations I just did it and I think
that's the best way to do it because
then nothing feels rehearsed you're
completely yourself and I think just
being open and you you can't over plan
it now you're saying because they don't
they don't they can see through it if
they feel like it is rehearse or you're
saying what they what you think they
want to hear right but all that they
want is to know who you actually are
someone being herself Corrine the new
villain from this season of The Bachelor
I'm
more colorful okay I think that Corinne
is obnoxious and she's you know annoying
and all of those other things but the
one thing I will say about Corinne is
that she doesn't intentionally go out to
get the other girls the only reason that
she's been mean is in retaliation to not
else being mean to her the villains that
I don't like are the ones who are
bullying and right being mean to the
other girls and she's not really being
mean she's being herself and the other
girls just don't like it they don't I
think they're resentful of her because
Nick likes it